[Music]
be careful of mankind Diana what is this
place who are you people we are the
bridge to a greater understanding right
what is your mission well here's the
thing you are in more danger than you
think if you choose to leave and may
never return
how would I be a feisty
the gods gave us many gifts this is
where we keep them it's beautiful
today we celebrate the first heroes we
ever meet our moms from the beginning
the shield us protect us and inspire us
yoga trainer until she is better than
even you there are our real-life Wonder
Woman remind us every day that the
greatest power of all is love join us
today as we honor mothers around the
world and tell the world why your mom is
your greatest heroes
[Applause]
we got some new footage to break down
and you guys will be really happy about
this we got the best possible news that
DC EU fans could ever get there's a new
brand of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so you
guys are gonna be so happy with what's
going on behind the scenes with the
Wonder Woman movie right now just to
address that footage first obviously
there's the funny part with them
reminding to call your mother and thank
her on Mother's Day for giving birth to
you Queen Hippolyta is Wonder Woman's
mother she doesn't explain it too much
in the clips here but it's always who
her father is the changes in the comics
how she comes into being her origin
story has changed a couple times and
people are wondering if they're gonna
change her origin story again just a
little bit for the movie to make it a
little more hardcore because right now
there are two big versions of Wonder
Woman there's the Wonder Woman who was
born from a lump of clay and gifted life
by Zeus in two there was the one that's
just the natural-born daughter of Zeus
and Hippolyta one has god-given powers
the other one is a full-blown half-god
demigoddess and in the comics she's even
become the god of war herself several
times so the other new footage that they
have in here is when she's looking at
the god killer sword in Hippolytus
telling her this tale these are all the
gifts that the gods have given us and
little girl Wonder Woman is like oh my
god that's badass can I play with that
and she's like no nobody is strong
enough to wield that least of all you
like she definitely does not want Wonder
Woman to become a tool of war why would
that be there are a lot of theories
about that I'll explain the biggest one
but a big part of the movie is in Wonder
Woman becoming the warrior that you know
her to be from the comics in the really
cool thing that you might have missed is
that in modern continuity as well as in
classic Greek mythology Hippolyta
queen of the Amazons is daughter of Ares
in Wonder Woman is Hippolytus daughter
with Zeus meaning that Wonder Woman is
one-quarter Ares so the theory right now
is that that's going to drive some of
the big conflict later in the movie but
obviously there's so much stuff going on
I'll probably make a separate video kind
of explaining how the Pantheon works and
who's the son and daughter of who
because it's all one happy big
dysfunctional family
so expect to get a taste for that during
the movie right now in the comics she's
a little more chill
she used to be way more stabby
especially during the new 52 in a lot of
the new 52 aesthetics pepper what's
going on in the movies right now
especially a lot of the visual style of
the injustice universe just the most
heightened hardcore version of the
characters that you've ever seen part of
the fun of the Wonder Woman movie is
just meeting the Amazons who we haven't
seen before
the most hardcore group of warriors on
the planet and in addition to that them
filling out a lot of the lore of the DC
EU because they're so long-lived and
there's this whole supernatural side to
the Wonder Woman character that we
haven't even gotten into yet we've dealt
with aliens we've dealt with the more
grounded Batman elements of the DC EU we
know that cold but what about the gods
do they exist are they still alive
how do their powers work is it like the
Marvel Celestials gods with a little G
is it not like the all-powerful presence
which is the actual god of the DC
Universe when the movie comes out and we
all know exactly what the gods are like
in the Wonder Woman movie then I'll
explain the presence because he's kind
of a weird character and he's almost to
Opie for them to use him in stories
because it's like why wouldn't God just
step in and fix this if he actually
cared about what was going on you know
he doesn't care about what Darkseid does
he doesn't care about what the new gods
do he doesn't care about Batman
otherwise he would have saved his
parents in Crime Alley so he's just not
a very fun character to use in stories
that's why you use the little G gods who
do all kinds of crazy stuff but the
other big reason why I wanted to make
this video is because we got some of the
best news ever
they conducted some of the earliest
critic screenings for the Wonder Woman
movie in everybody is unanimously
positive about it saying pretty much
everything that you want to hear about
the Wonder Woman movie usually the worst
thing is silence everything that
everyone has been saying people that I
trust that actually do reviews I'll
address that too because a lot of people
get into the rotten tomatos drama stuff
yes there's a lot of crazy stuff out
there typically I would recommend that
you just find the people that review
stuff that you trust listen to what they
say about things and just forget about
all the other span that's going on so
people that I trust actually got to see
the movie and they're saying that patty
Jenkins did an amazing job she's
rate with actors which is exactly what
you want to hear about directors the
film is super dark but gal gadot and the
Amazons shine super bright that just
means that it's super hardcore but
there's a lot of heart and a lot of Hope
in it so you get the badass Wonder Woman
that you want to see but it's not so
dark and depressing as some of the other
DC movies have been so far and maybe you
like that in the movie there'll be a ton
of that so you will really enjoy those
parts but one of the big things that
Jeff John said a long time ago after the
big backlash last year was that films
need to have a sense of hope and if it's
missing you really feel it it feels so
much lesser in the film falls flat
so Wonder Woman is totally on it's a
game most of the praise the people have
been showering on the movie are for a
gal gadot specifically and patty Jenkins
obviously there's a lot of other stuff
going on in the movie but there's an
embargo up so people aren't allowed to
say very specific things about it
sometimes I get invited to see movies
early if I do have a chance to see it
it's not out for about three weeks as
I'm posting this I'll do a non-spoilery
review but all these positive reactions
from real critics that I trust are just
the best possible thing people will
always go crazy for movies and
characters that they love regardless of
how good movies actually are so
sometimes it's hard to parse whether a
movie is good or not just depending on
who's shouting about it what does this
saying is that the more level-headed
people are saying that this is a really
good movie and it just makes me so much
more excited for Justice League I was
already really excited and I've been
listening to a lot of the behind the
scenes chatter about the influence of
Geoff Johns in how he's bringing heart
back to the DC EU just like he's
bringing heart back to the comics with
DC rebored so the future of the DC EU is
looking very bright even though the
movies will be generally pretty hardcore
compared to the Marvel Fair there's a
lot more comedy happening in the Marvel
movies now and there is a lot of comedy
in the DC EU but I think you know
Justice League is a good example between
Justice League and Thor Ragnarok one
movie will be a really humorous big
action set piece one will be a really
hardcore big action set piece with humor
in it so if that doesn't get you excited
I will show you this picture of Henry
Cavill trolling us like a master with
more Green Lantern and if you are
wondering there is a Green Lantern in
Justice League just not the Green
Lantern that you think
and not in the way that you think so
I'll do another video about justice Lee
again soon but leave all your video
requests for Wonder Woman DCE you Batman
Justice League stuff what's gonna happen
next is is there was a little new Rick
and Morty that dropped I'll do a video
for that but they'll be new Game of
Thrones and there'll be some new Marvel
stuff happening on Sunday
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner it's blue beast please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details so
while you wait for all that new stuff
you can click here for brand new flash
and you can click here for my Thor
Ragnarok guardians of the galaxy
crossover explainer thank you so much
for watching let's high five I'll see
you guys tonight